will say like oh
it's cause they don't like you enough
and I just never felt like that was like
I fucking hate when people say oh
he just didn't like you
like that he just didn't like you enough
um you're gonna have to
or when people say this about themselves
about their own relationships
they're like oh
I'm gonna have to watch the next girl get treated the way that she deserves
the way that I deserved to be treated
just because he's gonna actually love her
and she's gonna
pull out all the traits and characteristics in him that I just couldn't
because I was just an inferior woman
like bitch
oh my god obviously people aren't publicly saying out loud like
I'm just an inferior woman and that's why he treated me the way that he did
but that's like the underpinning right
that's the quiet part
cuz let me say something controversial here
I was treated so horribly
I was treated the worst by the one man that I've been with
who I think actually had really deep and true feelings for me
I think that those two things are like
not related I think that they're not correlated at all
I think that men
because of patriarchy
this is how men suffer under patriarchy
I think that they're willing to shoot themselves in the foot
and they're willing to sabotage their own happiness
just to not lose their sense of control and power
I think that a man can have really true deep feelings for a woman
like I think that a man can love a woman and still treat her like absolute shit
like I think that's what happened to me personally
might be controversial to say
but that's my lived experience personally
but also regardless of whether or not he had deep feelings for you
it's possible to not have really deep feelings for someone
and still not treat them like shit
the reason why men treat women like shit is because of patriarchy
hello it's because of
like the ways in which our system is set up to allow men to get away with shit
okay I'm just rambling now at this point cause I'm a little tipsy
but listen I've been watching Bridgerton
like we all have been
I watched Bridgerton today
and watching Bridgerton
I think about the fact that like
when a man did something dishonorable once upon a time
if a man treated a woman in a dishonorable way
um meet me at dawn motherfucker
pistols drawn
like we're gonna duel over this
nowadays it's not like that anymore
men just do whatever the fuck they wanna do and their homies don't check them
and obviously women don't have the power to check them anyway
stop taking the way a man treats you personally
men do not act rationally
the way that they feel about you
the way they feel about a situation and um
you and who you are
and your character and your value and your worth
not correlated at all to the way a man treats you